This question is something of a test of your vocabulary. Shading refers to per
vertex versus per pixel. With Gouraud being per vertex and Phong being per
pixel. We're given the per pixel will be considerably more costly than per
vertex. So this side of the grid will be more expensive. Illumination refers to
the Lambertian diffuse model versus the Blinn Phong specular model. Since the
Blinn-Phong model builds on the Lambertian model, adding shininess, it must be
more costly. So the top part of this grid will be more expensive. These two
facts establish that Gourand and Lambert is the quickest and Phong shading with
Blinn-Phong illumination is the most expensive. The tie break between these
other two combinations is that per pixel shading is given to be much more costly
than vertex shading. This tips the balance so that Gouraud shading and
Blinn-Phong illumination is faster than Phong Shading and Lambertian
Illumination.